presumptive democratic nominee joe biden
announced kamala harris as his pick for
vice president
in case you missed the wall-to-wall news
coverage here are some things we thought
you should know about her background
her record and how president trump might
target her during the campaign
harris was born in oakland california to
her jamaican father
and indian mother she did undergrad at
howard university
got a law degree from the university of
california hastings
then started her career in the almeida
county district attorney's office
in 2003 harris became the district
attorney for the city and county of san
francisco
she went on to become attorney general
of california and a u.s senator
harris ran for president in 2020 and
looked like a serious contender for
months before she dropped out of the
race in december after performing poorly
in polls
she ultimately suspended her campaign
after failing to garner
broad support she went on to endorse
biden even though the two had famously
classed on the debate stage
it was hurtful to hear you
talk about the reputations of two
united states senators who built their
reputations
and career on the segregation of race
in this country and it was not only that
but you also worked with them to oppose
busing
in a statement biden said harris was
quote smart
tough and ready to lead he also
mentioned he first met
harris through his son beau who was
attorney general of delaware when harris
held the same office for california
when it comes to harris's record reviews
are mixed especially during her time at
the top levels of law enforcement
former aides say harris told her staff
to not prosecute cases that resulted
from arrests based on racial profiling
she also created a program called back
on track
which had the goal of keeping low-level
offenders out of prison if they went to
school and kept a job
but critics have pointed out that harris
avoided intervening in cases involving
killings of suspects by police
in 2014 there were calls for her to
investigate a series of shootings by san
francisco police
during national protests over the death
of michael brown and ferguson
but as attorney general of california at
the time she declined
saying it was not her job except for in
quote
extraordinary circumstances david campos
who was a former supervisor and police
commissioner when harris was district
attorney in san francisco
said of her quote you have someone
saying all the right things now
but when she had the opportunity to do
something about police accountability
she was either not visible or when she
was she was on the wrong side
in more recent memory paris has received
praise
and media attention on the national
stage president obama called her
brilliant
dedicated and tough and even caught
flack for saying she was the best
looking attorney general in the country
harris was also routinely in the public
eye grilling trump administration
nominees and administrators
including brett kavanaugh during a
supreme court confirmation hearing
two years ago so how might the trump
campaign go after harris
well not long after biden announced her
as his vp
pick an attack ad dubbed harris as quote
phony kamala accusing her of rushing to
the radical left
embracing bernie sanders plan for
socialized health care
and calling for trillions of dollars in
new taxes
slo joe and phony kamala perfect
together
wrong for america it's also likely
harris will be attacked for being a
flip-flopper
on issues for example as attorney
general
harris defended the death penalty even
though she was personally against it
she was also criticized for overseeing
over 1900 marijuana convictions in san
francisco
which was considered overly aggressive
and hypocritical given that she now
supports legalization
and last year harris admitted she had
smoked pot in an interview with a
breakfast club
joint it was a joint hey yeah can you
remember to hide
i do finally it should be noted that if
the biden harris ticket does win the
election
kamala harris would make history by not
only being the first woman vice
president
but also the first african-american and
first asian american
but of course there are still many weeks
before november
and harris will have her first big test
on october 7th
in salt lake city utah where she'll go
head to head with vice president mike
pence for round one
of debates